ciao
bene a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video io sono ottimi e su
questo abbiamo accolto la sfida di
vodafone trame power e curo liri dove
vodafone sta lanciando questa nuova
offerta per una rete fissa molto potente
insieme ad una nintendo switch con un
prezzo molto speciale e noi cioè io e
mio papà sfideremo buffer curo lily che
appunto alleneranno i rispettivi
genitori quindi dobbiamo impegnarci
giocato a mario kart per la nintendo
switch pronto prontissimo prontissimo
allora questo è il trofeo fumo questa è
una delle piste più maledette perché
praticamente tu devi prendere i turbo
allora la cosa più importante che se tu
schiaccia il tasto a quando c'è il
secondo numero quello che mi premuto
adesso di crudo parti più veloce
bravissimo bravissimo adesso è esatto
bravo no no devi andare a destra che
stiamo raschiando
prende bene vieni sempre premuto perché
se non vado avanti e poi giri tra in
questi casi sono turchi quindi stanno li
prendi mai più veloci questi così
azzurro tipo allora adesso se tu vai su
tutti inquadrati bravo e con questo
questo dito qua viper schiacci il tasto
r1 che questione r1 gira gira forse con
schiacciare schiaccia questo come questo
sia in quello lì non altro scusami e
loro spazio a destra destra che si senta
sia l 1 dei satiri turati che puoi usare
usa lotte e le un bravo hanno ancora
ancora bravissimo adesso è un'altra un
altro oggetto che puoi usare bravissimo
a destra adesso gira gira gira bravo
mesi terzo nel male se primo di adriano
oggi la
guardai sull'arancione l'arancione la
più veloce sull'arancione quello il
fronte di girare in pratica era fi
sull'arancione l'ipo che perfetta di sua
zia sic tutto a sinistra ha portato vii
vii settimo torinese abbiamo fatto sette
su dodici
[Musica]
l 1 le un perfetto non sul guarda non so
come hai fatto a fare questa cosa che
non era possibile sbagliato ad un
assetto sempre 7 la partenza di
bra veline dove niente piacere non a
caso pagina per via
schiaccia l
era bravissimo che mia incredibile preso
un tizio a caldo ma la spiaggia non fa
niente per questo no no la tua banana
l'anomia 9 dritto dritto dritto
benissimo ma frutto reco al secondo e al
terzo persone male poi la roba vai sul
blu il blu ma vai a destra della destra
ai blu pensavo quello di romeno che
perché correva e by anche adesso però il
muro questo ma da ok perfetto è dritto
dentro non fare la sente male che non
pregiudica è solo un ostacolo
incredibile bene ultimo adesso facciamo
un'altra cosa facciamo la sfida nel se
si prova a giocare anche io come prova
per vedere se effettivamente si può e
quello ti fa che sei stato bravo ma in
realtà è pagato per farlo perché sono
facciamo la sfida improba questa è la
sfida vera come prima come prima tu sei
a sinistra sono a destra va bene
riguarda solo quel lato lì in due uno
dei schiacciate tutto quello che non fa
niente dai campagnano non ho neanche
capito che avevamo partiti vai vai sul
schiacciati sempre piano 1 poi finisce
turbo lo schiacci l'altro e sono gli
sprechi tutti subito
bravo io sono arrivato neanche prima
prima tu hai fatto terza neanche molto
male la sinistra sinistra sinistra
sinistra bravissima rischiato no
dodicesimo non te lo meritavi dono ma
non è almeno un settimo lo poteva non
melo che ritrovato bravo bravo sia un
secondo e primo sono io quello davanti
primo primo primo pazzesco pazzesco
incredibile primo primo primo vai vai
vai il primo girone concluso primo a un
nota peccato è chiaro non solo per cui o
sano equilibrato niente perché hanno
spruzzato la solar avere provato a
destra adesso
quello è un casino e calamaio scusa
volevo quindi adesso sono sentimenti
presentino settimo sempre settimo motore
simile al 1 però non
sia a casa sia ce n'è uno sempre sempre
sempre sempre bravissimo se resto sesto
san giovanni c'è sempre una sempre
un'agilità allora questa è la più come
non lo so se la più complicata se non è
sì
bravo vice piacere uno schiaccia adesso
sono frutti ma è sempre limitato non è
però dovuto guardare perché non lo
prenderemo preso un frutto che schiaccia
va bene
gira schiaccia al taglia tanto c'è
intuivo taglio a presentare nell'anello
addirittura cioè il turbo per by
schiacciano schiacciano piace ancora
veloci sicuro ci sono ci sono ci sono ci
siamo visti moltissimo dai e qui
non c'entrano come del resto è anche una
ultima mi concentro tutto sulla partenza
poi basta i provini di trento e poi c'è
il muro che volendo poi prendo con
l'azzurro va bene a non fare pensa buono
tra 100 e buonissimo numero 134 questo
qua a destra c'è il muro
a milano secondo destro bravo credibile
capiamoci giorni
ma perché c'era alcuno perché qualcosa
accade di tanti
ma una cosa ho fatto perché mi rovinano
ste cose nel paese l 1 sempre molto sei
iscritto sono contese diritto
bravissimo bravissimo previsioni si
guarda bene ancora e uno schifo per
un'altra volta non se forse arrivo di 17
tutto ciò che
disse vai dritto per lui non c'è niente
che trovano settimo vabbè dai non è male
visto che prima di nono settimo hai
fatto in totale sei arrivato mi sa
settimo anche se ottavo non li sotto già
allora risultati finali dopo queste
incredibili partite abbiamo al primo
posto eccolo qua questo sono io
come come mi chiamo sono del tartufo io
sono aiuto prima 54 punti e dopo c'è
ladrone poi dai nomi vai
pernacchia quello mi sembra ok poi lui
incazzoso hai detto bene poi nell fo che
non sono ai co.co.co su red bull red
bull red bull e poi ci sono io eseguo
martino che sei ottavo se ottavo beh
allora siamo arrivati comunque ottavo
per non aver mai giocato secondo me non
è malissimo non aver mai tentato un
joystick d'aiuti dieci anni non è
malissimo e comunque non ho idea leader
risultato che avevamo fatto un culo
lilly and power ma spero
peggio di opt out comunque che secondo
me è ottavo
grazie papà per questa questo impegno
incredibile ma il card quindi ragazzi a
sfide finita abbiamo dimostrato di saper
giocare in famiglia anche se lo sapevamo
già bisogna capire se quello di repower
hanno fatto meglio o peggio ma seguite
anche le loro sfide soprattutto votateci
sul profilo ilsa grandi vodafone perché
molto molto molto importante comunque
ragazzi partecipate anche voi se volete
e quella nuova offerta appunto di
vodafone che ti permette di avere una
rete fissa la massima potenza insieme
alla l'inter lo switch ad un prezzo
vantaggioso e trovate per tutto questo
link.in descrizione quindi ragazzi spero
che mi sia piaciuto con la solita
stupida ma bisogna solo quanto mi piace
anche vari social committee tutta la
descrizione senza che si rischia e non
ci vediamo come sempre ai ragazzi
[Musica]